okay let's go through some interesting
stories from the david pakman show
subreddit where nearly 8,000 of our
viewers and listeners are subscribed for
free to discuss politics and debate the
news respectfully david pakman.com slash
reddit our EDD IT is where you can find
that very interesting article posted
this morning on the subreddit about new
evidence of anti-semitism with regard to
the women's March co-chairs this is an
article Emmie tell you a story about
this article I have been covering the
anti-semitism linked women's March
co-chairs for a very long time at this
point and for the most part the audience
appreciates it but there are still
people who reach out to me and say David
you're just wrong you're wrong there's
no evidence of anti-semitism linked to
the women's March co-chairs tablet
magazine published a devastating article
with specific conversations and a whole
bunch of new allegations regarding
anti-semitic links and the reason I'm
not covering it separately is that I've
already covered it so much it's just
more confirmation of what I already knew
but here is an interesting tidbit
journalists I am in touch with who have
tweeted about written about this report
about anti-semitism within the upper
ranks of the women's March have been
approached by a PR company claiming to
have sort of counterpoints
counterfactuals to the allegations made
in the tablet magazine article and from
what I've reviewed so far and I can't
say who shared it with me because they
are being approached and only told they
will be given this list of
counterfactuals on the condition of not
talking about it for the time being the
counterfactuals are very shaky so there
is actually an entire PR effort now to
try to defuse what are increasingly
credible claims of anti-semitism within
the ranks of the women's March the
women's march leadership I want to be
clear about that no surprise I've been
talking about this for more than a year
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit an interesting post which is a
video I had never seen before years ago
our friend Sam cedar over at the
majority report appear
on CNN when the entire concept of the
war on Christmas was ramping up and Sam
debated some religious apologist who
believed that there really is a war on
Christmas or there was at the time and
Christians are being discriminated
against Sam trolled it so brilliantly
suggesting that Christmas may be linked
to terrorism and that they figured it
out by torturing an elf I mean just
brilliant trolling and I don't know if
you've watched this Pat but neither the
host Kyra Phillips nor the guide Trump
was debating Bob something had any idea
how to handle it and it's just one of
the most brilliant pieces of corporate
media trolling I've seen well the host
couldn't contain herself that I really
enjoyed I thought it was very funny and
to this day I don't know if the war on
Christmas has been won or lost I don't
know who won or lost it what's been
going on with that yeah who are the
players in the war on Christmas how do
you define winning and losing and given
the fact that almost everybody continues
celebrating Christmas in the United
States something like 90 percent
celebrate Christmas at least to some
degree it's it's it seems like a war
that whoever is waging it is doing an
extraordinarily poor job of because
Christmas still seems to be alive and
well check that out that's linked to on
the subreddit david pakman.com slash re
d di t submit your stories submit your
guests suggestions for the show submit
your criticisms about me there is no
shortage of those on the subreddit but
keep them respectful please because we
have moderators making sure that you
can't keep it clean on there we couldn't
have it any other way